-My first guest
is a legendary performer
and one of the biggest stars
on the planet.
He's a multiple award-winning
actor and comedian
that's been making us laugh
for the past 40 years.
His highly anticipated sequel
"Coming 2 America"
is available on Amazon
Prime Video on March 5th,
next Friday, March 5th.
It is going break
Amazon Prime Video.
That's how funny this thing is.
Here he is, Eddie Murphy!
Eddie, thank you so much.
-Hey, what's going on, man?
Thanks for having me.
-Ah, are you kidding me?
I always love having you here.
I appreciate this.
The last time
you were on our show
was a little over a year ago
when we had people
in the audience,
and you were hosting
"Saturday Night Live"
for the first time in 35 years.
-Yeah.
-And you knocked it
out of the park! I loved it!
-Yeah, that was a great
show-business moment for me.
To go back to the show and have
the show be as good as it was
and for so many people tune in,
that was a great
show-business moment for me.
-For everybody.
Everyone needed --
It was just so perfect,
and it was funny,
and you won an Emmy.
Congratulations for that.
-Oh, yeah, yeah.
That was the cherry on top.
-Yeah, that was the extra jam,
'cause you go,
"Wow, I'm just doing this
for fun."
-That was like, you know,
winning the basketball game
at the buzzer by dunking
and you shatter the backboard.
-[ Laughing ] Yeah. Oh, my God.
-Yeah. Then they lift you up.
-It was a moment like that.
-They lift you up, yeah.
What was it like
going back to Studio 8H and --
What was your memory?
Were you like, "Oh yeah --"
What was the night like?
-It was surreal. It was surreal.
And I was tripping of off
how it's the exact same --
You know, it's the same --
They've been doing that show
the same way for 45 years.
It's a trip.
The exact same way.
So it was a trip. It was like
going back to high school
and them giving you
your old schedule.
and be like, "Okay,
I have lunch at this today.
I got science at 12:00."
That's what it was like.
But it was bunch of
new students, though.
You sit in your old classroom
and look at my old locker.
It was that kind of --
-It was so good.
Congrats on that.
I just loved every single thing.
Honestly, I was nerding out.
And it was just well done.
It was just
a home run, home run.
Speaking of home runs, I got to
talk about "Coming 2 America."
The sequel is something
that people have been wanting
since the first one
came out in 1988.
Why was now the right time?
How did you know to do it now?
-We never thought about
doing a sequel to the movie.
We thought it was over,
'cause the story ended
with him going off.
It looked like they was going
to live happily ever after,
and that was
the end of the story.
And then the movie became
this cult movie, like, you know,
of all the movies that I've
done, "Coming to America"
is the one that like worked
its way into the culture
in all these different ways,
little catchphrases
from the movie.
Quest used to have a band called
"The Randy Watson Experience."
Questlove. He did.
He used to have a little --
So it's like you have
stuff like that.
And you have, like, on
Halloween, people get dressed up
as characters from
"Coming to America."
There's a restaurant
in New York -- I mean in L.A.
that on Halloween changed itself
into McDowell's Restaurant.
And they have, like, Sexual
Chocolate milkshakes and stuff.
So it was like, yo, this movie's
like a cult movie, you know.
So I was like, "Yo."
So, it took 25 years
for it to become that.
Then I started to, you know,
thinking, "Hey, if I could
figure out a way
to connect those dots,
we could do a sequel
to those movies."
And I got an idea, and it all
kind of came together.
-Can you set up for everyone
where the sequel picks up?
-The sequel picks up
30 years later,
and we're right in the middle
of our happily ever after,
and then we have to deal
with a very modern problem.
[ Laughs ]
Our fairy tale is disrupted
by a very modern problem.
-Mm-hmm. Yep. Exactly right.
It is so beyond funny.
I want to -- I mean, just crush.
I mean, just crush.
You doing all your characters.
The barbershop crew is back.
Arsenio doing
the other characters.
Leslie Jones, by the way --
Wow.
-Leslie Jones, Leslie Jones,
talk about -- Leslie Jones
in this movie is insane.
-I mean, everyone's home
right now.
We need something funny.
It is so funny.
-Nice. It's funny, light, funny,
put a little smile
on your heart.
It's a nice little movie.
I'm so proud of it.
-And the spoilers -- I don't
want to spoil everything,
but Wesley Snipes.
-Wesley Snipes.
I had just did --
Last year, I did
"Dolemite is my Name"
with Wesley Snipes.
And we had such an incredible
time making that film
and had just such strong
screen chemistry,
I just wanted to work with him
right again.
We went right into this.
The role that he's playing
in the movie,
originally, I was supposed
to play the General Izzi.
I was supposed to be
the General Izzi,
and I was supposed to be
the witch doctor,
and it was like,
Wesley would be so much better
in that role than me,
'cause Wesley can be menacing.
If I would have been
the General,
I would have just been funny,
and it would have been me
being threatened
by one of my characters.
It wouldn't have been the same.
But Wesley brought
this whole other [bleep] to it
and just jumped off the screen.
-He's menacing but funny.
-And funny, yeah.
You know, people forgot about
that Wesley could do everything.
'Cause Wesley became famous
for doing them action movies
and became this big action star,
people forgot
that Wesley can do drama.
Wesley can do comedy.
Wesley can do action, movies.
-"White Men Can't Jump."
-Yeah, -"White Men Can't Jump,"
"To Wong Foo."
Wesley is the great
Wesley Snipes.
The great Wesley Snipes, yo.
Yeah, he crushed this movie.
-And I have to -- Randy Watson,
Sexual Chocolate.
-That's my favorite
of all the characters to do
is Randy Watson.
If I could figure out a way
to do a whole Randy Watson
movie, I would do it.
He's a funny character.
-The mic drop.
I've seen this on the Internet.
There's a debate.
There's something going around.
People say that that is
the very first-ever mic drop
in the history of pop culture.
-Yeah, I don't know what anyone
is debating about,
'cause I heard somebody say --
Somebody was like, "Oh,
it started with the rappers."
The very first mic drop ever,
ever, where it's like,
what I said was so --
you know, so fly,
there's nothing left to say,
and I'm dropping the mic,
that's Randy Watson.
Now, in 1983,
at the end of "Delirious,"
I threw my mic down
and it slid down to the ground,
but that wasn't a mic drop.
I said, "Thank you. Good night."
I throw the mic down cool.
It wasn't like a, you know,
I crushed and dropped.
The very first one to do that
is Randy Watson.
-Wow.
-And I defy anyone
to find any footage of anyone
doing that before Randy Watson.
-Yeah, I agree.
What was it, Whitney Houston,
what did he sing?
He sang --
Why did he drop the mic, again?
-Yeah, he was --
"The Greatest Love of All."
-"Greatest Love of All."
-And he crushed it and dropped
the mic at the end of it.
-Oh, my gosh.
-And you know what?
That was improvised.
That was an improvised moment,
and the name of the band,
Sexual Chocolate,
that night,
I must have said 10 --
Every take, I would say
a different name to the band.
"This is my band So and So."
And it would just get
more and more ridiculous.
Then that was the ridiculous one
that stayed in.
But somewhere, there's
all these other names
of that band that night.
-Sexual Chocolate.
I'm telling you --
-Sexual Chocolate is insane.
-That is the dumbest name
I've ever heard in my entire --
-[ Laughs ]
-It's levels of funny.
It's levels.
But you know, someone should
make a real Sexual Chocolate.
Just call the Willy Wonka people
or whoever makes chocolate bars,
Hershey's or whatever it is.
-Amazon did this cool thing,
promotion for this film
on Valentine's Day.
They sent out
all these chocolates
with Randy Watson's
picture on it.
It was Randy Watson's
Sexual Chocolates.
There was a picture of Randy
singing to the chocolate.
It was hysterical.
-I want to show a clip
and hopefully --
It doesn't even do the film --
I'm telling you,
if you want to laugh --
Everyone needs
a laugh right now.
If you want some heart,
just get together
with whoever you can in your pod
or whatever you can do,
call somebody and say,
"Let's start it at this time."
You will love this movie.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Eddie Murphy
in "Coming 2 America."
Take a look.
-Soon, Nextdoorian warriors
will assassinate me.
I have a child on the other side
of the world.
-Take heart in your grief.
You are King now.
Be as your father.
Bark orders at me.
Throw things at me.
It will make you happy.
-Prepare the royal jet.
We are going back to America.
-Oh, hell no, Your Majesty.
-More with Eddie Murphy
when we come back, everybody.